beaucoup de français et beaucoup de
témoignages nous ont montré que laurent
wauquiez avait la niaque la
détermination la solidité intellectuelle
la force de ses convictions et surtout
il parlait directement et de manière
très concrète aux français je pense vous
savez vous qui est convaincu non je peux
vous dire que c'est mieux qu'un sondage
ce sens des retours de terrain c'est une
réalité partagée et et je le dis de
manière très honnête je crois que il a
fait l'une de ses meilleures émissions
politiques depuis qu'il est entré en
politique
pourquoi parce qu'il a mis du concret
parce qu'il a mis deux lames et parce
qu'il a surtout démontrer aux français
que sa politique et notre politique
simple ce serait une droite de
conviction qui dit ce qu'elle fait qui
fait ce qu'elle dit alors laurent qui
joue surtout aussi la carte de la
proximité avec les français il ya un
chiffre qui est intéressant dans un
sondage qui vient d'être publiée dans le
figaro emmanuel macron est considéré
comme plus proche des gens que laurent
wauquiez c'est tout un pan de son
argumentaire qui s'effondre finalement
non aujourd'hui laurent wauquiez est
moins connu qu emmanuel macron et que
donc c'est forcément ça a un impact sur
les sondages mais je crois pas qu'ils
aient d'adhésion populaire des français
emmanuel macron maniema ils
reconnaissent quoi emmanuel macron ils
reconnaissent qu'il a réussi la fonction
présidentielle mme après françois
hollande et honnêtement c'était pas très
compliqué mais il n'y a pas d'adhésion
ils disent quoi ils disent mais
finalement il n'est pas de notre monde
il est pas comme nous une représentant 7
à 10 également alors convoqué oui parce
que laurent wauquiez
c'est un site en construction il n'est
pas encore connue l'avantagé la force
car laurent wauquiez c'est justement cet
ancrage sur le territoire c'est qu'il
connaît le réel c'est qui sait ce que
c'est quand on parle de la fracture
médical quand on parle des problèmes
d'accès au très haut débit et autres et
donc c c'est ce qu' il veut faire vous
savez 15 806 d'imagés quand on parlait
de votre sondage du figaro
dans ce sondage malhonnête on doit pas
honnête ni sympathique ni la compétence
et sont là
n'en rajoutez plus la coupe est pleine
la réalité oui mais la réalité c'est que
quand on dans ce pays on veut dire des
choses on est forcément accusé d'être
qui vend incompétents et malhonnêtes
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que laurent
wauquiez il est qu'il n'est pas connu
par tous les français
eco et plus il sera connu et plus il
sera populaire et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important parce qu'on l'a vu moi j'ai
eu des messages dans les me suite à
l'émission politique et je peux vous les
montre et je les ai avec moi qui de gens
qui n'étaient pas qu'ils sont pas
forcément encartés qui était d'ailleurs
interrogatif sur laon wauquiez qui se
disent oui m'a convaincu parce que lui
au moins il a le courage de ses idées et
de le courage de dire ce qu'il pense et
ce que beaucoup français alors il y
avait un bon sondage c'est celui de la
fin de l'émission un tradi finalement il
a fait plutôt un bon score le problème
c'est qu'il y avait très peu
téléspectateurs 7% seulement de part
d'audience est-ce que c'est pas
finalement ça le problème le problème de
laurent wauquiez c'est à dire qui il
arrive à convaincre son coeur de cible
mais que cette cette base électorale
finement est très étroite savez on n'est
plus en campagne électorale et que donc
une émission politique a forcément
beaucoup plus d'impact en campagne
électorale que hors campagne électorale
je pense que c'est un examen sur la
question de la base
la base c'est un enjeu vous avez raison
il faut d'abord être solide chez soi